hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast and automated cancer
organoid culture platform to accelerate
research and drug screening I'm Christie
jewel of leverage and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab routes and
sponsored by get Co by thermo Fisher
give Costel culture heroes is a program
putting PhD and postdoc researchers
around the world in the spotlight for
more information on our sponsor please
visit thermo Fisher comm forward slash
cell culture heroes
now let's get started I would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them in the ask a question
box and click send
you can also see at the top of the page
multiple tabs please click through our
related applications upcoming and
on-demand webinars as well as links to
the cell culture heroes webpage you may
be our next cell culture hero also
please notice that you can share this
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab and
let your friends know that about today's
event now if you have trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or you can let
us know you're experiencing a problem by
using that ask a question box this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit I would
now like to introduce today's presenter
Brooke Schuster PhD candidate at the
University of Chicago for a complete
biography on Brooke please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
Brook you may now begin your
presentation
you
Thank You Christy for that introduction
I would also like to thank disco and
thermo Fisher Scientific for inviting me
to share my research it has been a few
years in the making and I'm so excited
to finally get to talk to you all about
my project
for today's presentation I'll I have
included an outline and what I will be
covering I'll first start with an
introduction about myself in my lab then
on to the background of the project
following with the development and
experimental progress and finally touch
on future work and outlook
located in the United States in the
heart of the Midwest Chicago Illinois is
the third largest city in terms of
population in the country and is home to
many wonderful universities including
University of Chicago
University of Chicago is just south of
the downtown area or what we called a
loop in a Chicago neighborhood called
Hyde Park the University of Chicago has
been consistently recognized to be one
of the top 15 universities in the world
with highly ranking science and medical
programs as well as globally ranked
business and law schools so a little bit
about me my name is Brook Schuster I was
born and raised in the Chicago suburbs I
then attended University of Illinois
urbana-champaign and more of the rural
part of Illinois right in the center of
her state and I completed a Bachelor of
Science in both integrative biology
honors and chemistry so here's a fun
picture it's actually not a picture of
me with horses but this picture was
taken right next to the first lab I was
ever in and the lab was part of the
school of veterinarian medicine and it
was when I first ever learned cell
culture and specifically I worked with
primary equine stem cells or horse
though I am now you know doing something
different as a fourth-year PhD candidate
at University of Chicago in the school
of molecular engineering
at University Chicago I'm a member of
the Tang lab which is which I am
mentored by professors Abbas take the
tail ab centers around bioengineering
and systems biology our labs model is to
understand model manipulate complex
biological systems and to do that we
develop high-throughput automated micro
fluidic systems that can perform
quantitative dynamic measurement with up
to a single cell resolution so we've
developed many different types of micro
fluidic devices many of them capable of
cell culture and even single cell
culture however is this presentation we
won't be focusing on single cells but
more are multicellular organized
so now a little bit about the background
of the project and why I develop it this
technology
so I would like to start by briefly
discussing organoids
I do not want to go into too much detail
as there are many cell cultures zero
presentations that dive deeply into why
organoids are becoming such an important
tool in research so please check out all
those wonderful presentations if you
want to learn more and haven't already
but I definitely want to briefly touch
on why organoids is so important why we
develop this whole technology based on
them
so in summary organoids are artificially
grown masses of cells and tissues that
represent organ they can derive from
differentiy tissues and beat or
differentiated tissues and be polyclonal
or be derived from stem cells and be
clonal so typically they're embedded in
a 3d matrix to provide support to these
3d structures so this can be a natural
ECM the hydrogel or extras or
extracellular matrix hydrogel which can
be typically derived from mice sarcoma
cells and examples of products would be
nature gel or gel tracks or they can be
more synthetically derived hydrogel and
this becomes very important when we
think about culturing and developing new
technologies for these organized so
overall many studies have shown how they
can reproduce the in vivo architecture
some of the functions and the genetic
signatures of these original tissues
so looking to compare organoids to other
methods especially in focusing on in the
realm of cancer so most commonly used
and traditional 2d cell culture
monolayers have no tumor cell
heterogeneity it grows very clonally
such as representing one cell grown in
the tumor and overall they tend to be
genetically unstable they require
mutations which ultimately limit the
number of passages you can grow them
which is very different from the
organized for example I have one
patients organoid growing up in the 70s
for passage numbers then in comparison
to mice models or what we call
patient-derived xenograft which is where
we take a sample of the patient's tumor
and plant it into a mouse you can
overall be very time consuming and
costly have a very low throughput and
you also have problems with the mouse
and human interaction in your
experiments
organize have been derived out of many
different organs here are just a few
examples they can be drive from both
normal tissue and cancerous tissues and
then we even have organoids to represent
different diseases like cystic fibrosis
so there's many different applications
for organoids overall they have shown
potential in biomedical applications
translational medicine and potentially
personalized therapies today we'll be
focusing on the personalized cancer
therapies or disease therapies to
demonstrate my technology but we also
could apply this technology to the other
applications as well
top is primarily a technology talk the
cancer I'll be focusing on to
demonstrate this technology is pink
erotic cancer so previously published in
the journal Molecular Cancer Research by
colleagues and our collaborators and
Kevin white club they developed patient
specific organized so these are derived
from the surgical samples obtained
during the pancreatic cancer removal
surgery from tiny different patients and
these are all patients and the samples
were collected from our very own
University of Chicago hospital and they
examined in their paper the phenotypic
and genetic features of these organize
and then compare them to their original
tumor for all these ten patients
so sneaking in from my own data into
this introduction here is some more
images of pancreatic cancer organized or
specifically we have patient-derived
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma
organoids so like the ducts of the
pancreas you can see that the organized
are hollow in the inside and so
organized
unlike monolayers or to these structures
they are 3d structures too so to fully
image them we take different defects or
image slices of the organoids so these
are fixed and stained you can see the
blue these are Daffy seeing or a nebula
stained and then the red is the Floyd
and stained or actin
so why is pancreatic cancer important to
model so pancreatic cancer is currently
the third leading cause of
cancer-related death in the US and it
recently suppressed breast cancer so for
example when I first gave this
presentation for my candidacy exams
it was currently number four so rapidly
changing and then it's also expected to
surpass colon cancer by the end of this
year to become the second leading cause
is unfortunately one of the few cancers
that survival has improved substantially
for more than 40 years so currently we
have no early detection tools to
diagnose this disease during the early
stages and in combination with this
large genomic landscape as being with
this image variations between patients
makes it very difficult to treat
focusing in on the main purpose of my
projects project with organize
established as a physically relevant
model for both basic and clinical
application there becomes a need to
improve the speed cost and
reproducibility of culture and
comprehensive screening of these
organize such as looking at the
phenotypic changes and drug sensitivity
so we aim to develop an integrated
platform that we can advance research on
organoid models screen and mirror
real-life patient treatments and
potentially facilitate treatment
decisions for personalized therapies
one way to achieve these objectives
involves the creation and
standardization and miniaturization of a
phase ran in parallel that can be
performed in a highly reproducible
environment with the utilization of
minimum amounts of reagents using a
automatic system that allows users to
culture in screen thousands of
conditions with minimum training and
investment and so the use of
microfluidic technology needs all of
these requirements
so the lab on inlet a lab is known for
having expertise in creating different
types of microfluidic cell culture
devices for all different types of
functions and experiments last year we
published eight 1,500 chambers cell
culture chip with individually
addressable chambers we even have a ten
thousand chamber prototype
so with our previously developed
technologies we have created automated
control high throughput and parallel
assays viable cell culture and
individually addressable culture
chambers
however it's a requirement of a
extracellular matrix such as hydrogel
that is usually temperature sensitive
which means we work with it when it's
and we embed the organoids
into it when it's cold around four
degrees Celsius and then as it warms up
to room temperature is solidifies
so this is important to support the 3d
cell culture and its ability to survive
however this makes all these previously
developed technologies obsolete through
the clogging of the fluidic channels
also most of our devices are around a
hundred to two hundred micrometers tall
and these would not be able to
accommodate the large organ or size
which is around four hundred
so outside my lab people have attempted
various microcytic devices that are
indeed compatible with this hydrogel but
they tend to fall short on being
high-throughput and being able to
accommodate this organoid size
so how about organoid culture outside of
microfluidics so most common is these
plate based experiments to add
automation people tend to use these
automated imaging systems but overall we
still have limited high throughput with
these automated imaging systems
there's no intervention during the
experimentation you stick it in the
system to the images image for your drug
treatment and you can't touch it during
it and then overall it tends to be very
costly in labor intensive especially
when you think of terms of number of
pipetting steps
so now we know what we want to achieve
and our goals are defined and we know
about the different components well
let's talk about how we developed
technology to meet our needs
so the final develop platform ended up
being a two-part system
so we'll start with the first device
which is our organoid culture chamber
device
so resting on top of a glass slide
fitted into a microscope slide holder
the first layer of the device is a two
hundred chamber well layer it's made out
of a material called PDMS which is a
polymer that's clear enough to see
through while also being bio compatible
the design of the vise is geometrically
engineered to accommodate the large
organized size with its tall chamber
height while also being really easy to
pipette into to accommodate the hydrogel
and here's a example of me pipetting the
device this is the only pipetting step
for the entire experiment super easy I
can probably do it in less than two
minutes
are loaded into the chambers a second
PDMS space channel layer rests on top of
the well layer and this is reversely
bonded through a clamping base system
consisting of a clear plastic top the
screws and knobs knob to seal the device
together as being in the upper left-hand
corner
so here's once those devices put
together here is a side view of what it
looks like so combined with the well
layer
the channel layer provides the fluidic
channels to provide growth media during
the experiment or in the beginning of
the experiment and then as you go later
on to the experiment you can provide
other drugs or other chemicals stimulant
to the organoids so most complex PDMS
based microfluidic devices are made from
PDMS layers or multiple PDMS layers that
are permanently bonded together usually
through plasma bonding but to
accommodate this hydrogel we had to make
the bonding reversible through the
clamping based platform but this also
has imposed to it in addition to being
able to accommodate the hydrogel for
evil with this platform we're able to
easily harvest the organ oil after the
experiment is completed for you know of
data or off device data collection or
packaging the organoids after the
experiment is complete so both the
chamber we have the deep gel chambers
around 600 micrometers and the channel
height were specifically engineered to
provide a suitable 3d environment or the
large mature organoids growing below and
then we also the channel height allows
for enough liquid nutrients in the
channels to the growing organoids
without disrupting or washing away the
gel based environment below so with it
being soaked on a microscope platform
we're able to easily image all these
organized continuously during the entire
experiment and here's the example of
what one well looks like at 10x
magnification with actual organizers in
it
all this entire 3d culture tumor
platform was also engineered and
optimized to reduce elbow formation and
prevent leakage or interference or cross
communication between the different
channel
completed we have 200 chambers capable
of up to 20 different conditions whether
these are different organ a growth media
or drug cocktails or other chemicals
stimulants and we can hold up to 10
different patients at one
so now that we have our home floor
organized we needed to design a system
to automatically provide their growth
nutrients and then experimental
stimulants so here's an example of a
typical microcytic setup first we have
our built in incubator to keep our
organized and alive and happy for the
entire duration of the experiment I've
done experiments for over two weeks and
the organoids were super happy in the
entire time in the system so with the
microscope we also have a automatic and
programmable image acquisition and then
finally we have the main part of the
microfluidic system we have our
experimental control and so this is
controlled by a separate computer
connected to an array of solenoids out
valve as highlighted in the top green
circle and these valve controls are
helped control the movement of fluids
through a pressurized valve system and
this is what we will be calling
microfluidic Bell
so how do these micro [ __ ] Lou how do
these micro Switek valves work so micro
fluidic devices previously designed by
our lab typically consists of a
multiplex valve system to move fluid and
cells in many different ways these
valves are based on valve designed by
the quake lab in Stanford so how they
work is they so you have the solenoid
valve array connected to your computer
that the computer tells the valve array
when to apply pressurized water this
pressurized water then goes into the
specialised channel which I have labeled
labeled as the pressure splash control
layer in that light blue and once
they're activated they provide
resistance to the media layer or what we
call the flow layer which is where all
of our media or drugs would enter so we
have the valve closed media stops
open-close open-close
so however with this these gel based
cell culture systems such as organized -
um these would dramatically decrease our
throughput and efficiency if we try to
use these valve based systems directly
with our organ or each cell culture so
in order to prevent that we develop a
second device to control and automate
our experiments
so moving on to our second device we
have the multiplexer control device in
this consists of a multiplex array of
different vessels that can control the
movement of various solutions so are
currently device holds up to 30
different solutions and they can direct
them to various channels or multiple
channels of organoids in various timing
dynamically
how this device connects with our
organized culture device first we
connect our solenoid valve array and
that's opening and shutting our micro
fluidics valve and here's example of the
image again and then we have our media
or drug or other chemical inputs and
says inserted on the top portion of the
device we then connect this device to
and from our organoid home and then we
can collect the waste from the organized
here on the device and then we finally
have our experimental control that tells
the device exactly what we want to do
whatever experiment we want and to
control this we can upload a file as
simple as a excel file to tell the
computer what type of experiment we want
to run
and then essentially is once you hit
start it's all hands-free and the
experiment along with automated imaging
runs on its own so overall this
integrative system provides
communitarian and then dynamic drug
simulations in terms of hundreds of
cultures and real-time analysis of
organoids so focusing in on cancer we
validated our system by facilitating
individual combination and sequential
drug screens on human drive pancreatic
tumor organized
to talk and I'll be talking about a lot
more in the upcoming slide but so the
unique feature of the system is we're
able to do dynamic or sequential drug
treatment and that means so typically
when you receive a combination
chemotherapy in clinic you don't get all
three drugs given to you at once instead
you get one drug at a time through an IV
and so to demonstrate that we delivered
those drugs away that most neared how
you would receive them actually in
clinic on that platform as we wanted to
compare it to traditional methods where
they would do a drug testing where they
test all three drugs given at once so
more detail coming up with it so with
our platform developed a like to
introduce some of the experimental data
with the use of the platform and
pancreatic cancer organized along with
fda-approved chemo therapies to fully
demonstrate this platform in action
but before we want to begin the drug
test testing we look to established
organized growths on the platform so
here's three different patients grown in
parallel from single cells to
multicellular organized in just seven
days and you can see there's different
size and shapes of the organized in
comparison to the different patients
so through this continuous imaging
process he ends up with so much data you
know we're taking different focuses of
these organize and at many different
time points during the growth process so
to keep track of those growth we want to
quantify these images so here's example
of some quantifications
of these organize growth for each
patient over time so each dot represents
an individual organized area and then a
line fitted on top of these organized
what you're able to compare the
different patient's growth rates to each
other so like a patient's cancer is
unique so are there organoids
so here's an example of this organoid
growth video and so we have patient 1
we're going from single cells to
multicellular organize you can watch
them grow here's what patient - and you
see a hydrogel bubble so the platform's
designed to remove those so it doesn't
affect her Imogene
and then finally patient 3
okay so to confirm our platforms did not
affect the development of these original
organized we did at HMA analysis to
confirm their morphology was consistent
between systems so to do that we
collaborated with dr. Chris Webber
who's the pathologist at University of
Chicago and also helped develop these
organoid he confirmed that between the
traditional plate based systems and the
microfluidic
platform that the morphology stayed
consistent for both patients for example
patient patient one made a consistent
moderately differentiated morphology
with necrotic luminal cells and then
patient four was well differentiated
with more uniform features
and as I teased you guys in the intro
with some of these images we are able to
on this platform not only fix in singing
organized but we can always take
different image slices or Z staff
acquisition of these organized image
acquisition too and which in turn will
allow us to be able to do a complete 3d
reconstruction of these organized on
this platform so here's 0 micrometer 257
micrometer in different image slices and
again you can see how the organoid is
hollowing the inside and then through
these images and confocal imaging system
we can take 3d reconstruction like this
so finally and we looked at being able
to test drugs sensitivity through the
use of imaging and the help of two
fluorescent detectors we have coquetting
an iodine for cellular death and then we
which is in red and then we have
caspase-3 seven for apoptosis in green
so first we tried to do the more
traditional methods where we just did
four hours of drug treatments then
replaced with normal growth media for a
duration of and then watched the
organoids for 72 hours and then we also
did a complete 72 hours duration of
these fda-approved chemo therapies so
here's our just a few image examples we
have the negative control which is just
our normal growth media we have
gemcitabine for four hours gemcitabine
for the full 72 hours we have a commonly
used chemotherapy combination which is
gemcitabine and paclitaxel and then
overall we compare all our drug
treatment data to a positive control
which is unknown apoptosis inducer in
organoid
so to see this on action here is example
of a video so all we had the face
contrast the green apoptosis and red
cellular def all overlaid to each other
and then essentially resign from no
drugs the strongest drug from left to
right
so again we have called these images
terabytes of data but you know how can I
tell which drug was most effective so we
had to develop a way to analyze all this
image data so here is example of all
this image data quantified so this is
just looking at the apoptosis which is
the green sustain for first single drugs
and then combination drugs and then to
the left we have the 72 hour of
continuous drug treatment and then to
the right you just have the four hours
then after the four hours it's just
replaced with normal growth media and as
expected the combination of drugs was
more effective than just a single drug
and then we have the 72 hour was overall
more effective than the 4 hour drug
treatment
so I briefly showed our commonly used
fda-approved chemotherapy drugs in the
last slide but to go over them in a
little bit more detail I also mentioned
so patients do not receive all three or
two drugs all at once instead they can
I'm going to specialized delivery so I
wanted to be able to mimic that near how
the patients receive them in real life
on my platform so to do that I looked at
how they actually received it and I
developed a tiny and floral here not
whole series full fox gemcitabine and
5su and then gemcitabine and paclitaxel
the left is just a cartoon illustration
and what I did and then again I
quantified the images of use now dynamic
and combinatorial drug screening
well this is cool we want to be able to
like how does this dynamic delivery
compared to traditional systems of doing
it 72 hour or 4 hours so for each of
these different combinations I've
compared them to the design dynamic to
the 72-hour or for our counterparts
interesting enough for this patient I
found out that the dynamic was more
effective compared to the 72-hour and
for hours looking at just the endpoint
stay in analysis for all these different
combinations for all of them the dynamic
was significantly different from the for
our treatment and then for all of them
except for the last one which is gym
side being and Pacolet axial the dynamic
delivery was more significantly
different than the 72 hours delivery
is especially interesting if we think in
terms of drug concentrations you're
getting one drug at a time first of 72
hours you get all three drugs at once so
that's just a overall higher drug
concentration so organoids are receiving
at one time so it's very interesting to
see that dynamic was more effective
so of course you know the main aspect
and milking or the main focus of our
technology is that we want to be high
throughput as well as dynamic so here's
a heat map illustrating all those drug
combinations and all the different
timings delivered to three patients at
once and this was all in one device one
experiment so we have patient one
patient to patient three select we have
that green stain the apoptosis and then
to the right and with the red we have
the cellular death so when I analyze all
these data each of these the cell death
images and apoptosis images and seen to
the right are completely different set
of images they are not the same image at
all so it was interesting to see and it
was confirmation of the data analysis
system that you see the consistent drug
sensitivity signatures between the
apoptosis and cell death between each
patient then also comparing each patient
to each other you see different unique
drug sensitivities between the patients
as well
so now that I showed the technology and
action and the data we acquired you know
what some of the future work and outlook
for this platform
so just briefly some potential future
works on this platform so the first idea
that we want to look into is called coal
culturing on this platform so previous
studies have been published and shown
that organoids can be cold cultured with
other different cell types on this
platform the one thing you could do is
if you coal culture with cells to
represent the stroma you can kind of
recreate this tumor micro-environment
you know also called culture these
organized with immune cells as well
we also would like to look into
chemotherapy drug resistance studies and
one way of doing this is that we've been
developing organoids derived from fine
needle aspirate respirations so this is
different from developing them from
surgical samples so we are able to take
a sample from the patient before right
when they're diagnosed before they ever
have chemotherapy and surgery and then
compare the organoids later on - or the
compared to their later on when you
obtain the organoids through a surgical
sample and see if their drug sensitivity
is genetics change
and then as shown with a different
application of organoids the
applications of for organoids on this
platform can really be endless for
example it's just a few example as you
can use this platform for Villa noid its
development sees which media works the
best for them to grow or other disease
studies
and then finally so with this image data
I keep on mentioning that we end up with
terabytes of data so are we able to look
and use machine learning based
techniques to automatically analyze all
this data for us
and so briefly to show what we've been
working on is that so to develop a
technique I've been working with an MD
PhD candidate named Sarah who's a
machine learning and developing models
expert so we first wanted to look at can
we automatically segment these images so
there currently are techniques for 2d
cell culture to segment images and to
segment the cells however you look at
this image all my organoids are
different sizes there's different
textures they're in different Z focuses
and different image planes and it makes
it very difficult to use current
techniques you can also see in the
middle we have a media bubble which
traditional techniques might pick up as
an organized but using our model we've
been able to automatically segment it
using a computer but here's just one
example what if I throw in images that
look different we have different cell
concentrations different number of
organized you have different shapes and
sizes of organized we have different
textures and no matter what we threw at
it it was able to predict with high
accuracy segmenting the organoids
so using this same technique would be be
able to protect so this and this would
prevent the need for these fancy
freshmen sighs can we just predict you
know how many organize are alive and
happy or dead based on just the bright
field or phase contrast imaging so just
some brief preliminary work on this
model you can see we have actual death
same to luck and what the model
predicted and this was based on the face
contrast imaging that models did not see
the preference and now we have the same
well of organoids however with this time
they're completely dead and left you can
see what the actual death scene is and
then right what our computer model
predicts so please look out hopefully
we'll have this published in the near
future
so that includes my presentation for
today please feel free to connect with
me on my various social media platforms
to keep updated on my research and
publications I've been trying to post
more and more about my scientific work
including many organoid videos I'm now
ready to open up for any questions that
you may have
Thank You Brooke for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we will answer as many
questions as we have time for okay
Brooke let's get started we've so many
great questions coming in already let's
begin with this one have you tried other
organize besides pancreatic cancer
organoids on the platform
yeah we've actually have tried :
organize that we got some some
colleagues at University of Chicago and
what's cool about those they're not
cancerous they're benign organoids
so it shows that it doesn't need to be
cancer and then we've also have played
around with some cell lines for example
MDA and B two three one a breast cancer
cell line we grew in 3d cellular
aggregates on the platform I do hope to
do more types of organize in the future
is the plan
Kingsbrook now instead of the 200 Wells
is it possible to custom design a
platform using 96-well plates
so the microscope that I showed you can
see it behind me in the little profile
picture but also in that previous image
that microscope is capable of any type
of well plates it could be you know
96-well plates or 24 well plate my
platform itself you can also I have a
800 well which had a larger wells made
out of PDMS as well so that's very you
can make that to whatever amount of well
do you want 200 is just the most optimal
and then using so when you use well
plates in the microscope setup it will
not be automated anymore so you would
have to hide pet if you wanted to change
different drugs you would have to take
the well plate off in pipette and then
reset all your images so it does make it
a lot more difficult but it is possible
what now this question is two parts what
size are the organoid wells and how much
media does each channel hold
so each of the wells are around 1.5
millimeters in diameter which holds
around one microliter of volume of gel
when you're pipetting it in so the
height of the weld is around six hundred
micrometers tall and the channel heights
are around 450 micro meters of height
and each channel which has ten wells
holds around 100 microliters of fluid or
media in the above the gels
and what's the average size of the
organize so this you know again varies
by patients some patients have organized
grow very largely very quickly and
others tend to be smaller in size but I
would say so when we do experiment we
look for the majority of them to be 100
micrometers in diameter to start the
experiment but by the end a lot of them
end up being 400 500 600 in diameters
what average definitely depends on each
patient
thanks Brooke our next question how do
you ensure channel-to-channel
consistency when using organoids in a
phase because they are spontaneously
generated in variant size and shapes
so yeah this is a very good question and
when I get a lot because you know when
to be cell culture you just count the
cells they all grow very uniformly but
organize you don't have that you're
dealing with patient cells
you know each organ ID and itself even
for one patient is different so to kind
of correct for that we first use
replicas and then another thing is all
my like for essence data is normalized
to account for the amount of organize
and then that's another reason we're
particularly interested in doing machine
learning and having those segmentation
images so we know exactly what volume of
organoids we have so very good question
and something we definitely consider
do you use only fresh boy ger organoid
for culture or can you save samples
under what condition and for how long
awesome yeah another good question so
all the organize I use for my
experiments weren't fresh because we had
a verified and confirmed that they were
indeed similar to the patient tumor in
that previous paper from the journal
Molecular cancer so my colleagues
confirm them so these organized have
been frozen down before they can be
trial preserved and woken up for
whenever you need them very easily
they're very robust and yeah some of the
organized we have frozen down and they
still wake up really easy there like
five plus years old I'm not sure exactly
how long and I don't know if anyone has
my answer but I do know that there's
current file banks for these organize
and that they can be proud to serve very
easily
Thank You Breck our next question also
has two parts how many Spears in the
single culture well and how do you
calculate every spear
so I I'm sure so they're spheroid and
organoids and my platform I haven't
tried culturing steroids but we I'm sure
it works so it works well with organoids
which are from primary cells well yeah
this is very similar to the previous
question about you know how do we
normalize or account for every patients
but I have a slightly different
population of you know in count of
organoids
so I say typically or the size well if
you have one veter maturing around 400
to 500 micrometers in diameter we have
around 10 per well and i forgot what the
second part of the question is can you
remind me I can yes um my apologies and
how do you calculate every sphere
yeah so you know currently have computer
programs to calculate those and not go
into too much detail or to explain more
stay tuned for when this paper gets
officially published and it will contain
more detail and exactly the processes I
use to calculate the ear area but it was
all through computer processing
no Brooke can you share with us one of
the problems you faced during the
development of the platform
so you know when you're making a device
it hasn't been created before it's a new
design you know there's a lot of trial
and error and you know one thing is when
it wasn't permanently bonded we had
problem with the platform leaking so we
just you know trial and error change you
know what is the design how we
engineered it to fix it another issue is
organize media for some reason is very
belly and like compared to normal you
know dmem cell culture media is just
like would bubble so easily and if you
think if you have bubbles that would
really affect your imaging so again that
came down to like how you know the shape
of the weld how the channels were shaped
and like the right right amount of
pressure and like to be able to
pressurize the platform to get rid of
those bubbles and then again that
connects to the leakage you're
pressurizing the system you don't want
it to leak so it took a lot of trial and
error but we got both of those issues
solved
Thank You Brooke how can you compare
growth if you are starting from
different sizes are you adjusting them
something
yes so I would normalize to the growth
of the first image so actually in the
more thinking about growth comfort
compared to like the drug sensitive
you
okay thank you now let's see let's go
with this question how long does it take
the organoids to grow before you
experiment on them and what size are
they at that point so how long does it
take organized to grow at what size or
how am i accommodating for the different
sizes so during the growth they actually
all start out as single cells so they
all are roughly the same size no matter
what patient it is
thank you okay I am let's see do you
make devices yourself and how long does
it take
yeah we do the whole process here at
University of Chicago we make the molds
ourselves so you know as I was saying
you can adjust the number of wells how
you want it and then we make the PDMS
devices here in the lab as well so for
the PDM device or PDMS device for both
of them I could make them
probably in two days but I make many
devices at once in a two day process so
we get a lot done pretty quickly
great and we have time for a few more
questions how do you apply pressure
through the chamber so the fluid is
pressurized through the multiplexer
device so the part you have the part one
organoid chamber device and then we have
the multiplexer so the fluid going into
Matt just the valves are pressurized
also the fluid flowing in is pressurized
through air around five psi
Thank You Brooke now it looks like we
don't have time for any more questions
what do you have any final comments
you'd like to leave our audience um
again I would like to you know everyone
feel free to connect to me here's like
all my social media handles and you know
don't be shy to reach out or if you
think of questions later I would love to
talk about it or if you guys if you have
any ideas or collaborations I'll love to
hear about it
and then I'd like to thank everyone for
attending I really appreciate people
coming and listening about my work
Thank You Brooke and I too would like to
thank our audience for joining us and
for their interesting questions again
just a reminder those questions we did
not answer today and those that are
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by Brooke via the
email address you provided at the time
of registration and I would once like to
thank Brooke Schuster for her time today
and her important research we'd also
like to thank elaborate on our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand and
laborat swill alert you via email when
it is available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event you will now be redirected to
the registration page of our next
webinar titled modified dental composite
for bone repair presented by Mayta
arshad on March 27 and 9:00 a.m. Pacific
time 12:00 p.m. Eastern Time we hope to
see you there have a great day
you